vamos a ver cuánto es cuatro enteros
entre dos tercios como siempre pausa el
vídeo e intenta averiguar lo bueno una
forma de encontrar la respuesta es
recordar que esto es lo mismo que cuatro
pues recíproco de dos tercios es decir
cuatro por tres medios y cuánto será
esto bueno puedes pausar el vídeo y de
nuevo intentar encontrar la respuesta es
muy fácil recuerda que el 4 lo puedes
ver en forma de fracción como cuatro
sobre uno por tres medios y ya hemos
multiplicado fracciones anteriormente
para hacerlo tenemos que multiplicar los
dos numeradores 4 por 3 es 12 y
multiplicar los dos denominadores uno
por dos es 2 entonces me quedan 12
medios que es lo mismo que 6 12 entre 2
y 6 pero la pregunta clave es porque
esto funciona porque es dividir entre
algo es lo mismo que multiplicar por su
recíproco y para responder esta pregunta
porque nos dibujamos 4
déjame tomar el color rojo
tengo un entero dos enteros tres enteros
cuatro enteros e imagina que vamos a
dividirlos en grupos de dos tercios de
entero así que déjame dividir un entero
en tres partes iguales el otro también y
el otro también y el otro también y haré
cada grupo de un color diferente aquí
tengo un grupo de dos tercios acá otro
grupo de dos tercios u otra sección que
representa dos tercios acá otra sección
de dos tercios acá otra sección de dos
tercios por acá otra sección de dos
tercios y la última sección de dos
tercios de modo que cuántas secciones
que representan dos tercios tengo bueno
tengo una dos estos dos tercios juntos
tres cuatro cinco estos dos tercios
juntos que forman una sección y
seis secciones por lo tanto puedo tomar
cuatro enteros y dividirlos en seis
secciones iguales de dos tercios de
entero en cada sección por lo que cuatro
enteros en tres secciones de dos tercios
de entero es lo mismo que seis secciones
hasta aquí el vídeo nos vemos en el
siguiente